Herr Lange wir sehen jetzt diese
massiven Angriffe russischen Angriffe
auf die Ukraine aus der Luft warum
greift Russland die Ukraine ausgerechnet
jetzt auf diese Art und Weise
an die Angriffe kommen leider nicht
überraschend man musste damit rechnen
dass Russland wieder das versucht was es
ja auch im letzten Winter versucht hat
nämlich ukrainische Infrastrukturen zu
zerstören Wasserleitung Stromleitung
Heizung heizkraftwer wke Transformatoren
diese Dinge Russland fängt mit der
Angriffswelle deutlich später an als im
vergangenen Jahr und versucht damit
genau vor die kalten Tage zu kommen in
der Ukraine soll es jetzt kalt werden
und Russland hat Raketen produziert und
hat sie aufgespart um so große Wellen
von Angriffen zu erzeugen das ist das
was wir in der letzten Nacht und auch am
29 Dezember gesehen haben diese Wellen
braucht Russland weil die Luft
Verteidigung der Ukraine mittlerweile
besser ist als noch vor einem Jahr und
man also ganz viele kombinierte Raketen
marassflugkörper Drohnen braucht um
durchzukommen äh das ist das was wir
gerade sehen leider muss man damit
rechnen dass Russland noch weitere
solcher Wellen auf die Ukraine loslassen
wird wir bekommen dazu auch schon fragen
bei Youtube und zwar unter anderem eine
Frage nach der Strategie also was
verspricht sich Putin denn von diesen
Angriffen gezielt eben auf Zivilisten
und zivile Infrastruktur
na das Ziel ist
die Lebensbedingungen für die Menschen
in der Ukraine zu verschlechtern und
auch die Unterstützung für die
Streitkräfte geringer zu machen die
Industrie zu treffen also die
Rüstungsbetriebe die Munitionsfabriken
vielleicht auch die Instandsetzung für
Fahrzeuge und für Militärtechnik aber es
geht Putin auch darum Bilder ins
russische Fernsehen zu bringen die
zeigen dass er stark ist dass er in der
Ukraine etwas anrichten kann gerade
jetzt zu dieser Zeit wo während der
Feiertage rund ums Neujahr bis zum alten
neuen Jahr am 15 Januar die Russen ja
weitesgehend zu Hause sitzen und vor dem
Fernseher sie haben es angesprochen also
die die die russischen bodentroppen die
kommen gar nicht oder nur sehr langsam
voran z.B bei der Stadt afdfka setzt die
russische Führung aktuell jetzt eben
verstärkt auf Angriffe aus der Luft weil
die Erfolge am Boden
ausbleiben zumindest gibt es nichts was
man vorzeigen kann aus russischer
Perspektive bei avdevka bei kupjansk bei
bachmud an anderen Orten versucht
Russland schon seit einigen Wochen ganz
massiv anzugreifen kann aber keine
Städte erobern ein paar 100undert Meter
geht's voran aber unter extrem hohen
Verlusten äh das sind natürlich keine
Bilder der Stärke und Putin braucht
Bilder die zeigen dass sein Krieg
irgendwie erfolgreich ist für Russland
in dre Monaten gibt's
Präsidentschaftswahlen in Russland das
sind zwar keine richtigen Wahlen und ist
auch klar dass Putin gewinnt wenn er
antritt aber trotzdem ist das für die
Stimmung in Russland ganz wichtig so
glaubt Putin jetzt in der propagander
diese Bilder zu zeigen und Russland hat
ein spezielles Verhältnis zu seinen
Raketen es gibt Lieder die über Raketen
gesungen werden jeder kennt die Typen
von Raketen das wäre bei uns ja nicht so
der Fall also das ist auch ein Symbol
der russischen Militärmacht wenn man auf
andere Länder Raketen schießt eine Frage
zu diesen Raketen haben wir auch bei
Youtube bekommen und zwar wieso setzt
Russland diese Raketen nicht gegen
militärische Ziele ein was würden Sie
dazu
sagen ja Russland setzt diese Raketen
seit Beginn des Krieges gegen
Infrastrukturen ein aber ganz bewusst
auch immer wieder auf die Hauptstadt
Kiev auf hakev gerichtet damit die
Ukraine gezwungen ist die
luftverteidigungssysteme auch die von
uns gelieferten z.B ihres tslm oder auch
Patriot in diese Städte zu ziehen weil
dann hat russ R Land die Möglichkeit an
der Frontlinie Luftangriffe zu fliegen
die Ukraine kann die
luftverteidigungssysteme dann nicht zum
Schutz der eigenen Truppe benutzen wenn
es damit die Städte und die Zivilisten
in den Städten benutzen
muss das ist glaube ich die ganz perfide
Überlegung auf der russischen Seite die
Ukraine militärisch auf diese Weise zu
schwächen wir haben jetzt auch in den
vergangenen Tagen die Darstellung gehört
dass diese Angriffe diese Angriffswelle
eine Vergeltung für ein ichen russischen
Angriff auf belgorot sein soll sie haben
jetzt aber schon gesagt das ist jetzt
nichts was man sozusagen innerhalb
weniger Tage plant und dann durchführt
sondern das ist was was deutlich
größerer und längerer Planung Bedarf wie
aufwendig ist es tatsächlich eine solche
Angriffswelle
vorzubereiten also mit diesen Angriffen
musste man leider rechnen und die
Vorbereitung für so eine Angriffswelle
dauern sehr lange denn es müssen nicht
nur die unterschiedlichen marschlukörper
und Raketen produziert werden das dauert
schon einige Zeit sondern die werden ja
von Schiffen aus dem Schwarzen Meer
gestartet von Flugzeugen über Belarus
von Flugzeugen über Russland über dem
Kaspischen Meer unterschiedliche
Flugzeuge unterschiedliche
Marschflugkörper die Routen müssen
programmiert werden die ganze Mission
wird geplant zeitgleich werden dann noch
Drohnen in den russischen in den
ukrainischen Luftraum gebracht also das
ist nicht etwas was man spontan als
Racheaktion über macht macht sondern das
ist systematische militärische Planung
die sehr langfristig erfolgt ist
diese Diskussion über eine vermeintliche
Racheaktion für belgorot ist glaube ich
eher ins Reich der Propaganda
einzuordnen aber leider muss man sagen
dass diese Propaganda immer wieder bei
uns hier funktioniert und dass Leute das
bei uns immer wiederholen ich glaube die
Russen selbst glauben weniger an die
russische Propaganda als einige Leute
bei uns das vielleicht noch weil sie es
auch noch mal angesprochen haben zu
belgorot als klein Ergänzung falls das
in meiner Frage gerade missverständlich
war also Russland wirft der Ukraine
natürlich einen Angriff auf belgorot vor
das noch einmal zur Klarstellung
wir haben jetzt schon über die Techniken
also über die Raketen gesprochen es gab
jetzt auf Kiev auch Kiev war auch massiv
unter Beschuss von Drohnen welche
Erkenntnisse haben Sie darüber was für
Technik Kriegsgerät da jetzt aktuell bei
dieser Angriffswelle eingesetzt wird ja
die Russen benutzen ja schon länger
shahiddohen und Weiterentwicklung von
diesen schahiddohen die aus dem Iran
stammen ursprünglich die sind jetzt
nicht besonders leistungsfähig die
Fliegen auch langsam und sind sehr laut
aber es gibt sehr viele davon und sie
sind billig und es geht glaube ich darum
die ukrainische Luftverteidigung immer
wieder herauszufordern und die Ukraine
dazu zu zwingen teure
luftverteidigungssysteme für billige
Drohnen zu verwenden die Kombination ist
das was es für die Luftverteidigung
schwierig macht also
kalibermchflugkörper die von Schiffen
gestartet werden
x 555 x55 X2 das sind alles Raketen die
von Bombern aus also von Flugzeugen aus
weit entfernt irgendwo über Russland
gestartet werden dann tausende Kilometer
fliegen und es gibt die kinjal Waffen
das sind sozusagen aufgemotzte
ballistische Raketen die von Flugzeugen
ausgestartet werden deswegen
hyperschallgeschwindigkeit erreichen
können die mit ganz geringer vorwahnzeit
und selten sehr Flug dann direkt auf
Kier fliegen von einem vom Luftraum über
Belarus aus das ist nicht weit weg also
diese Kombination aus den
unterschiedlichen Systemen macht es für
die Luftverteidigung sehr sehr schwierig
sehr beeindruckend was die Ukrainer mit
diesen Systemen die sie ja auch
sozusagen zusammengepusselt haben aus
allem was sie geliefert bekommen haben
was sie damit leisten sind vielleicht
jetzt die erfahrensten und besten
Experten was Luftverteidigung betrifft
eine weitere Frage die wir bei Youtube
bekommen haben da fragt uns jemand führt
Moskau verstärkte Angriffe aus der
Distanz als Vorbereitung für eine
offensive durch oder weil man
aufkeimende Unzufriedenheit über die
hurenten Verluste an Soldaten fürchtet
was würden Sie dazu sagen
ja letzteres man braucht Bilder fürs
Fernsehen die Stärke demonstrieren und
in Russland ist das schon so wenn man
seine Raketen irgendwo hinschießt dass
die Leute da eher oder viele Leute das
eher toll finden und glauben dass das
russische Stärke zeigt eine Vorbereitung
einer Offensive ist das auf keinen Fall
Russland ist nicht in der Lage größere
offensiven zu führen wird auch auf
nächste Zeit gesehen nicht in der Lage
dazu sein die jetzt bombardierten Städte
also hakiv oder Kiev mit einer Offensive
anzugreifen man sieht ja das was
Russland offensiv versucht nördlich von
avdevka oder bei kupjansk oder bei
bachmut das hat deutlich kleinere
Dimensionen und Russland kommt da ein
kommt da zwar voran aber ein paar
hundert Meter unter großen Verlusten
also wir reden hier nicht von großen
militärischen Operationen Russlands die
bevorstehen wen sie haben jetzt schon
gesagt dass diese Angriffswelle dass das
nichts ist was man mal eben sozusagen
aus aus dem Bestand durchführt sondern
diese diese Raketen und drohen die
mussten lange sozusagen aufgespart
werden wie viel Nachschub um es mal
Platz zu formulieren hat Putin denn
tatsächlich noch bzw wie lange wird er
das durchziehen können und wie viele
diese Wellen die wir jetzt gerade
erleben werden wir in diesem Winter noch
sehen na die russische Produktion
insbesondere von
marsflugkörpern war ja zwischendurch
einmal ins Stocken gekommen im letzten
Winter hat Russland viele Raketen
verschossen und auch aufgrund der
Sanktionen auch der technologischen
Sanktionen hat Russland viele Bauteile
z.B Mikrochips andere Dinge die es nicht
selbst entwickeln kann hat es gar nicht
aber in den letzten Monaten hat Russland
daran gearbeitet Sanktionen zu umgehen
Möglichkeiten zu finden über Drittländer
diese Dinge doch zu kaufen und dadurch
ist die Produktion an marsflugkörpern
wieder
gestiegen man kann davon ausgehen dass
Russland in der Lage ist im Monat von
diesen unterschiedlichen Typen dieser
mflugkörper etwa 100 120 zu produzieren
also Russland braucht einen Monat um die
Raketen für eine solche Angriffswelle
zusammenzubekommen die Russen haben
jetzt in den letzten Monaten wenig
Raketenangriffe gemacht also Raketen
produziert und aufgespart so dass man
davon ausgehen muss dass jetzt in diesem
Winter es waren jetzt zwei solche
Angriffswellen dass das russische
Material noch reicht um zwei oder drei
weitere solche Angriffe auf die Ukraine
durchzuführen höchstwahrscheinlich in
den nächsten Wochen während es in der
Ukraine sehr kalt sein wird wie kann
sich die Ukraine dagegen effektiv
verteidigen ja die Ukraine kann diese
Angriffe überhaupt nur überstehen weil
sie leistungsfähige
luftverteidigungssysteme bekommen hat
und die auch gut einsetzt dazu gehören
ja auch das deutsche IRS SLM aber auch
Patriot
nasams eine ganze Reihe von anderen
Systemen da haben die Partner der
Ukraine geliefert und tragen dazu bei
dass die Ukraine das überstehen kann das
ist keine hundertprozentigigen Schutz
gibt bei Luftverteidigung das ist so
aber es ist schon sehr beeindruckend was
alles ab fangen wird trotz dieses großen
Aufwandes den Russland betreibt wir sind
alle gemeinsam etwas langsam darin mehr
von diesen Systemen zu produzieren und
auch mehr Lenkflugkörper also Munition
dafür zu produzieren da muss die
Industrie nachlegen oder die zumindest
müssen die Staaten dafür sorgen dass die
industriellen Kapazitäten erhöht werden
Putin macht ja nicht den Eindruck dass
er irgendwie vor hat aufzuhören sondern
ganz im Gegenteil erersetzt darauf dass
wir vielleicht nachlassen oder nicht
genug liefern man darf sich aus meiner
Sicht aber nicht nur mit der Frage der
Verteidigung beschäftigen also für mich
ist es militärisch widersinnig dass man
sagt ja wir liefern Luftverteidigung und
die Ukraine muss die Raketen abwehren
können aber die Bomber also die
Flugzeuge die diese Raketen abfeuern
irgendwo über Russland und die dort von
basenstaaten oder die Schiffe im
Schwarzen Meer die darf man nicht
angreifen also ich glaube darüber sollte
man noch mal nachdenken und man sollte
auch darüber nachdenken was hat das
eigentlich für Folgen für Wladimir Putin
und für Russland wenn jetzt Russland
mehrfach die ukrainische Hauptstadt
heute früh als alle Leute auf dem Weg
zur Arbeit waren auf diese Art und Weise
angreift kostet das Putin irgendwas oder
zucken alle nur mit den Schultern und
sagen ja das ist halt so also es muss
Putin klar gemacht werden aus meiner
Sicht wenn er diese Angriffe weiterführt
dann werden neue Kategorien von Waffen
an die Ukraine geliefert dann tun wir
Dinge die bisher nicht getan wurden
damit er irgendein eine Art von Anreiz
bekommt mit diesen Angriffen aufzuhören
also ich glaube einfach nur zusehen wird
nicht ausreichen Herr Lange lassen Sie
uns gleich darüber gerne noch mal weiter
sprechen angesichts der russischen
Terrorwelle werden auch hier zu Lande
Forderung laut die Ukraine eben
konsequenter zu unterstützen unter
anderem von Marie Agnes Stck Zimmermann
von der FDP sie ist die Vorsitzende des
Verteidigungsausschusses im Bundestag
wir konnten am Nachmittag mit ihr
sprechen und da hat sie folgendes gesagt
Deutschland macht sehr sehr viel im
Kreise der europäischen Staaten am
meisten aber richtig ist dass die
Angriffe massiv sind und äh dass
offensichtlich wir Angst vor unsere
eigen Courage haben gemeinsam mit den
Partnern noch deutlich mehr zu machen
dazu gehört der Taurus
mararschflugkörper mit dem die Ukraine
sehr wirkungsvoll die den russischen
Angriff zumindest unterbrechen könnte
und ja es ist in der Tat so wir sind in
einem neuen Jahr und wir sollten nicht
nachlassen und die Worte wir sind an der
Seite der Ukraine solange Sie uns
brauchen oder solange es erforderlich
ist das ist richtig aber das heißt eben
auch dass wir auch nicht nachlassen
dürfen die Ukraine zu unterstützen mit
allem was wir tun können humanitär
wirtschaftlich und eben auch mit
militärischer Unterstützung heißt mit
Waffen also sie haben den Appell von
Marie Agne stagzimmermann gehört die
Entscheidung über eine weitere Lieferung
von Waffensystem wie z.B dem Taurus
marchwü Körper die liegt im Kanzleramt
was erwarten sie von Olaf Scholz Herr
Lange wir tun noch nicht alles was wir
tun
könnten und wir sind zu reaktiv das
heißt wir warten immer nur darauf dass
Putin etwas macht und dann langsam und
zögerlich darüber nachzudenken was wir
denn eigentlich jetzt tun wollen und
beides muss ich aus meiner Sicht im Jahr
2024 ändern Deutschland muss alles tun
was es tun kann gemeinsam mit den
europäischen Partnern das ist gerade
auch mit Blick auf die die Entwicklung
in den USA notwendig und da geht's vor
allen Dingen um industriekapazitäten
Munition aber auch um Wartung in
standsetzung von Schützenpanzern
Kampfpanzern die wir schon geliefert
haben und vor allen Dingen und das ist
der zweite Punkt geht's darum mal aktiv
zu überlegen was können wir eigentlich
noch machen und nicht immer nur wenn wir
gedrängt werden und wenn es nicht mehr
anders geht die Zielstellung die Ukraine
darf nicht verlieren und wir
unterstützen solange es notwendig ist
ist aus meiner Sicht zu wenig weil das
das Rezept sein könnte für einen sehr
langen Krieg unter dem die Ukrainer zu
leiden haben Putin hat offenbar
keinerlei Absicht irgendwie nachzulassen
oder aufzuhören also muss man ihn dazu
bringen dass er aufhört und nicht darauf
setzen dass er irgendwann irgendetwas
einsieht und mit diesem Krieg aufhört
und dafür müssen wir die Ukraine
ausstatten ich glaube es beginnt damit
ganz klar das Ziel zu formulieren und
spätestens jetzt zi Jahre nach
Kriegsbeginn muss endlich mal ein Ziel
formuliert werden das lautet die Ukraine
muss sich durchsetzen können militärisch
muss Russland aus der Ukraine vertreiben
und dafür müssen wir die Ukraine
ausstatten aber wenn ich sie richtig
verstehe das bedeutet ihrer Einschätzung
nach sollte Deutschland der Ukraine
taurusmschflugkörper liefern ja
natürlich sollte Deutschland der Ukraine
taurusmschflugkörper liefern die
Europäische
Gemeinschaft die jetzt F16 Flugzeuge
liefert könnte eine Gelegenheit dafür
bieten die Taurus z.B auf die F16
Plattform zu integrieren um dann
gemeinsam mit anderen Europäern diese
wirkungsvollen Systeme einzusetzen
Taurus hätte aus meiner Sicht schon
lange vorbereitet werden müssen
äh mit der
plattformintegration mit der Ausbildung
äh um bereit zu sein für diese
Entscheidung damit nicht irgendwann wenn
dann nach ganz langer Zeit die
Entscheidung getroffen wird erst die
ganzen Vorarbeiten losgehen ich finde
das misslich dass über so Einzelsysteme
immer wieder diskutiert werden muss
Deutschland sollte überlegen was können
wir noch tun um die Ukraine dazu zu
bringen dass sie sich militärisch
durchsetzen kann und Taurus gehört ganz
eindeutig dazu dazu gibt's auch eine
Frage von KTI Hübner die wir bei
Facebook bekommen haben also welche
militärischen Möglichkeiten sie ter lang
sehen Sie um die Souveränität der
Ukraine zu
bewahren russland hat doch seine
militärischen Ziele bisher nicht
erreicht ist doch nicht so dass er davon
sprechen dass man da einer unbesiegbaren
Übermacht gegenüber steht ganz im
Gegenteil Putin muss sich extremst
anstrengen um mit so einer Art
primitiver sowjettaktik wo er ganz viele
Menschen wie Menschenmaterial an die
Front wird ein paar hundert Meter
voranzukommen im Osten der Ukraine das
heißt wenn die Ukraine etwas mehr
modernes Material besser bessere
Technologien aus dem Westen hätte könnte
sie sich sehr wohl gegen Russland
durchsetzen es will ja auch niemand nach
Moskau marschieren oder Russland
irgendwie am Zeug flicken sonder es geht
ja nur darum dass Russland aus der
Ukraine zu zurückgedrängt wird das ist
militärisch möglich aber dafür muss man
schneller und mit industrieller
Unterstützung liefern und muss da auch
durchhaltefähig sein da geht's nicht um
Deutschland allein ich glaube da sind
die anderen europäischen Partner genauso
gefragt Frankreich Italien Spanien
können auf jeden Fall mehr machen machen
bisher auch weniger als wir aber das ist
jetzt die notwendige Überlegung ist
übrigens auch der einzige Weg wie man zu
einem Ende dieses Krieges kommen kann es
kann doch nicht unser Rezept sein zu
sagen wir lief dann immer ein bisschen
damit die Ukraine irgendwie überlebt und
der Krieg geht dann ewig auf diese Art
und Weise weiter Herr Lange wenn wir
jetzt über die verstärkte Unterstützung
sprechen und auch über z.B die Lieferung
von Taurus die das Argument in der
Debatte um die Lieferung von Taurus war
ja bisher dass man sozusagen nicht
möchte dass die Ukraine damit
gezielt Ziele auf russischem
Staatsgebiet
angreift wie sehen Sie das das wäre
damit ja sozusagen eine Position von der
mal abweichen müsste
na ich halte das Argument im konkreten
Fall von Taus für vorgeschoben die
Ukraine hatte das nie vor man kann das
auch durch technische Dinge ausschließen
hätte man schon lange vorbereiten können
das ist wenn man etwas nicht will dann
erfindet man Argumente um es nicht zu
tun wir sehen noch was die Ukraine mit
Skyp ej und mit stormshadow also den
ähnlichen mkörpern aus Frankreich und
Großbritannien macht und es geht darum
die Logistik der Russen und das
Aufmarschgebiet auf der auf der Krim zu
stören ähm den nachtschub über die
Brücken abzuschneiden das ist
militärisch ganz unbedingt notwendig äh
niemand will mit diesen marsflugkörpern
Taurus irgendwelche Ziele in Russland
angreifen mal abgesehen
davon äh muss man aber die
Grundsatzfrage
äh ist das eigentlich sinnvoll
äh dass die Ukraine sich sozusagen
Zusammenschießen lassen soll aber die
Militärbasen von denen die bomberstaaten
und die Schiffe die die Raketen abfeuern
nicht angreifen soll äh also das muss
man schon hinterfragen ob das sinnvoll
ist völkerrechtlich sind militärische
Ziele innerhalb Russlands auf jeden Fall
völlig legitim anzugreifen durch die
Ukraine wenn sie überfallen worden ist
wenn wir noch mal auf die
Waffenlieferung schauen haben wir eine
Frage bekommen von Mario bei Youtube und
zwar was sind eigentlich was sind die
eigentlichen Hintergründe warum die
westliche Rüstungsindustrie nicht in
Klammern so schnell hochläuft wie das
nötig wäre und wie auch Russland das
macht welche Erklärung haben sie dafür
Industrie braucht lange Zeiträume und
Vorlaufzeiten also wenn man sagt wir
brauchen mehr luftverteiligungssysteme
oder mehr Munition für diese Systeme
dann muss man sehr lange planen und
Kapazitäten aufbauen bis dann am Ende
mehr herauskommt das ist in der Politik
glaube ich nicht immer verstanden was
für lange Zeiträume das braucht deswegen
ist es so wichtig frühzeitig mit den
Vorbereitungen zu beginnen und die
Industrie muss ich natürlich darauf
verlassen können dass diese
Investitionen auch finanziert sind und
da gibt es insbesondere in Deutschland
aber ich glaube das gilt für andere
Staaten auch zu wenig Vertrauen dass die
finanziellen Zusagen am Ende auch
eingehalten werden und wenn man sich
anguckt dass aus 2% des brutto
inlandsprodukts die für Verteidigung
ausgegeben werden sollten plus 100
Milliarden Euro Sondervermögen jetzt im
Haushalt
2024 sowas wie 2% na ja aber für ein
Jahr und nur durch das Vermögen und
danach weiß man nicht wie es weitergeht
mit den Finanzen geworden ist kann man
das auch ein bisschen nachvollziehen
andere Staaten wie z.B die USA die geben
ihrer Industrie Abnahmegarantien und
sagen für die nächsten 5 Jahre oder für
die nächsten 10 Jahre kaufen wir alles
was ihr produziert und dadurch haben die
Unternehmen eine Sicherheit zu
investieren Leute einzustellen neue
Kapazitäten aufzubauen also über solche
Dinge nachzudenken gehört glaube ich in
Deutschland zur zeitenwender auch dazu
also sie fordern einen Strategiewechsel
mit Blick auf die militärische
Unterstützung der Ukraine was glauben
Sie denn wie realistisch ist das dass
sich da tatsächlich auf absehbare Zeit
was
ändert ja ich mag nicht darüber
spekulieren was realistisch ist ich kann
aber sagen was notwendig ist und
notwendig ist die Ukraine langfristig
industriell unterlegt zu
unterstützen und nicht erst wenn man
sozusagen aufgewacht ist weil Putin
nichts einsieht sondern den Krieg immer
weiterführt plötzlich hektisch zu
versuchen noch Dinge rumzureißen man
sieht ja wie das bei der
munitionsproduktion für die
Artilleriemunition leider nicht geklappt
hat nur eine Millionen Schuss zu
produzieren ich finde das peinlich für
führende Industrienationen ich glaube
ein Problem an der ganzen Sache ist aber
auch dass man gar nicht so genau weiß
wer ist denn eigentlich jetzt derjenige
oder diejenige die sich den ganzen Tag
nur mit der Frage beschäftigt wie kann
man der Ukraine
weiterhelfen wie kann man diese Dinge in
die Hand nehmen also man kann doch so
einen Krieg nicht wie einen Vorgang von
vielen managen und sich immer nur damit
beschäftigen wenn man gerade
kapazitätenfrei hat oder wenn gerade
etwas akutes passiert also da fehlt es
ein bisschen an Systematik und ein
Strategie das wäre gut wenn das im Jahr
endlich Einzug hält weil ich keinerlei
Hinweise darauf sehe dass Putin
irgendwie gewillt ist mit diesem Krieg
aufzuhören oder einzulenken oder
irgendwie weniger zu machen also kommt
es darauf an dass wir ihm eine
langfristige Strategie entgegensetzen
Herr langer ich möchte Ihnen gerne
abschließend noch eine Frage stellen die
wir bei Youtube bekommen haben die geht
jetzt sehr weit in die Zukunft ich
möchte sie aber trotzdem nicht unter
Tisch fallen lassen und zwar ab wann
können wir denn grob mit einer
ukrainischen Luftüberlegenheit
rechnen ja eine
Luftüberlegenheit auf dem gesamten
Gebiet der Ukraine wird aus meiner Sicht
keine der beiden Seiten mehr erreichen
können dazu ist das gesamte Land im
Grunde auf beiden Seiten der Front mit
hochleistungsfähigen
Luftverteidigungssystem viel zu sehr
gesättigt
äh das kann keiner mehr schaffen aber
lokale Luftüberlegenheit um z.B Truppen
am Boden etwas zu entlasten die könnte
die Ukraine herstellen sobald die F16 im
Einsatz sind an bestimmten
Frontabschnitten äh das halte ich auch
für wichtig insbesondere im Süden und
gerade dort
glaube ich dass die Ukraine Chancen hat
auf künftige Luftüberlegenheit dann mit
den F16 wenn die weitreichende Munition
für die F16 auch zur Verfügung gestellt
wird weil die Ukraine dort Radare
luftverteidigungssysteme Schiffe die
Luftverteidigung haben systematisch
ausgeschaltet hat mit spezialoperationen
und auch mit Präzisionswaffen und im
Grunde ganz gut vorbereitet ist auf
diese nächste Phase dann ab dem Frühjahr
also da könnte das Gelingen insgesamt
wird das keinem gelingen und der letzte
Punkt vielleicht noch zur
Luftüberlegenheit was der gesamte
Kriegführung sehr stark verändert ist
der massenweise Einsatz von drohen nicht
nur jetzt drohen die in Infrastrukturen
fliegen sollen sondern massenweise
drohen direkt über dem
Kampfgebiet und auch das verändert für
Luftverteidigung und für
Luftüberlegenheit die militärischen
Überlegungen sehr stark das erwähne ich
deswegen we ja abgesehen von dem was da
in der Ukraine passiert auch die Frage
sehr wichtig ist was lernen wir
eigentlich daraus und ich glaube die
Bundeswehr aber die Streitkräfte
generell in der NATO müssen aus diesem
massenweisen Einsatz von drohen äh sehr
sehr viele Lehren ziehen vor allen
Dingen muss man sich billige
Möglichkeiten zur Abwehr von Drohnen
überlegen weil man mit teuren äh
luftverteidigungssystemen die billigen
Drohnen nicht dauerhaft wird bekämpfen
könen